Browse the app,
I mean moving from one screen to another,
This is the basic part of Android development.
Historically, you can use intent or fragment interaction
To do this, in simple cases, such as clicking a button,
This is easy.
But what if you want to do something a little more complicated?
For example, connect a common pattern like bottom navigation.
You need to make sure not only your bottom navigation view
Really can navigate, but also
Highlight the correct button.
Oh, and it handles the background stacking in a uniform way.
This way the user will not lose direction or be confused.
A case like this is a new navigation component
Shining place.
The navigation component is a set of libraries.
A cocoa simplifies Android navigation
Plugins and tools.
In addition to making settings for common modes such as bottom navigation
Easier, the component also handles the background stack.
Fragment transaction, parameter passing,
Navigation-based animation and deep links.
The important thing is that it collects all of this navigation information.
And put it in a visual location in your app.
The navigation map.
Navigation components and clips and activities
Out of the box.
You can also extend its library to use other screen implementations.
For example, a custom view.
Let's take a look at some examples of actual navigation components.
One of the activities here will be exchanged
Multiple fragments.
If you want to know why you should consider
For a single activity model, check out Ian Link's wonderful presentation.
I added a video link to my notes.
it is good.
Therefore, the navigation component
By three main parts together
Coordination.
These are navigation maps, NavHostFragment
And NavController.
A navigation map is a new type of resource.
It is an XML file that contains and concentrates
Navigation related information.
Now available in Android Studio 3.3
Provided in the new navigation editor
This message is displayed.
It is a graphical editor to create
This navigation map.
Every screen is called a destination.
Or you can navigate to the place.
In this example, they are all fragments.
These arrows are called operations,
They represent the user can pass
Different paths taken by your app.
If you click on one of the actions,
You can see a lot of embedded information,
Including data passed between destinations,
Animation transitions, reverse stack operations, etc.
Click on the destination and you can see the deep link URL
And startup options and more.
This is all part of the XML of the chart.
Ok, next, we have NavHostFragment.
Suppose you are doing segment navigation,
This is a fragment widget that you will add to your layout.
It is basically a
Can be exchanged in and out of the navigation map
A window containing different fragment destinations.
The last fragment is the NavController.
Each NavHostFragment corresponds to a NavController
You will use it in Kotlin or Java code.
This is to indicate that navigation occurs.
s things.
So if I write code like this,
NavController will be based on the navigation map
All the information to perform this navigation,
And eventually exchanged
The fragment shown in the NavHost fragment.
Now I am using the XML ID of the operation
To specify the action arrow to follow,
But a better way is to use
The SafeArgs plugin for the navigation component.
The SafeArgs plugin generates code,
Allows you to use type-safe navigation
And parameter passing.
First, you add the Gradle plugin to your code.
This will generate classes based on your navigation map.
It will be any destination with operations
Create these "directions" classes,
And it will be any destination with parameters
Create an "Args" class.
If you use the original navigation statement,
You can exchange these generated classes,
And you will get the content shown below.
You should make sure you have it
The action associated with the destination,
Instead of having to reference an operation through its XML ID.
You can also set the parameters of the operation.
If the type of error is passed, the code will not compile.
Getting the parameters you pass is easy.
Just use the GeneratedArgs class,
You can only have the parameters that are correctly named
Type-safe access.
No need to worry about past key value pairs.
This is simple navigation.
Let's talk about setting the bottom navigation.
Navigation components include
Additional navigation UI library in Java
And Kotlin's KTX extension,
They support the options menu, bottom navigation,
Navigation view and navigation drawer.
It also applies to the action bar, toolbar
And folding toolbars.
For our bottom navigation, you can normally
Switch the bottom navigation to XML.
You can also pass
ID that matches your destination XML ID
And the navigation map you want to go to the bottom navigation
Create an XML menu.
Then you can use the navigation UI to connect the rest.
In Kotlin, you can use this handy extension.
This line of code has a NavController.
It handles the actual navigation,
Ensure that you follow best practices in material design,
In terms of reverse stack management.
Most importantly, it handles highlighting
The correct bottom button.
Now we only discuss
Some parts of the navigation component.
To learn more about navigation,
Please check out Codelab and related documentation.
All of this is in the link below.
I hope you have a pleasant coding and navigation experience.